Four most ecological cities - several cities have taken the
initiative in recent years to take a more ecological approach
to reducing global pollution and global warming.
These are the five greenest cities in the world.
Amsterdam Amsterdam is one of the cities with
nearly four hundred thousand bicycles,
which considerably reduces co-two emissions.
It was also named two thousand as the healthiest city in the world san
francisco rated two thousand eleven as the greenest city in north america
san francisco is a city with solar paneled buildings.
Moreover,
it is the very first city to have completely eliminated the
plastic water bottles covered wind,
considered as the city that emits the least carbon dioxide because it took the
initiative to ride hundreds of kilometers of bike paths and introduced the
importance of buying local products.
Reichiavic - this capital - supplies its homes with renewable energy.
Indeed,
only % of electricity comes from captown fossil fuels,
nearly 20% of its energy source comes from renewable energies,
which limits pollution of all kinds.